Oh everybody my name is Natasha this is
my channel and today I'm talk about our
reservations I made a really nice
collection and I created how'd it go
interesting so basically it is Albert
utilization se13 a public spectacle or
some idiot at my age generators and
other stuff today I would like
specifically to talk about two
algorithms
is genetic algorithm and if we have time
it'll be about finding algorithm so
let's start with genetic algorithm and
what genetic algorithm does if you have
some really complex task and you have
too many variables to create a formula
for it you can just try modifying those
variables and seeing if the result is
became a little bit better me and let's
take a look at an example so here we
have an energy of my lesson and we're
going to use genetic algorithm to build
this image out of set of polygons so
let's start at one
so right now just the one triangle it's
a polygon okay more what is it is trying
to do every step it tries to modify this
triangle a little bit so it might change
the shape it might change the color and
every time it does it it calculates the
difference between original image and
where we are so the difference is
calculated for each pixel basically you
just subtract the colors and let's see
how it works I'm going to get for
polygons here I can start so right now
we see ms a lot of triangles are being
added here and basically is it because
anything is better than just plain white
color the whole time we're going to get
this picture there is little parameters
here so on hope you can see fitness
function and can everybody's Jewish they
make it
so basically fitness function is the
difference between colors for each pixel
and improvement means that we tried
something we changed one polygon and the
fitness function to round 3 better and
then we keep it and it goes to the test
there are different ways of how we play
the polygons so right now it says video
and means that we're going to play each
polygon and we just going to change one
parameter so it will be either the shape
of the polygon or to go change that are
or three or three colors and if we try
hard for example it will be changing
always four parameters California so for
each polygon to just randomly create a
different time and see if it's better as
you can see now number of improvements
actually is not been feeding because
they images to defeat already and it is
pretty hard to get around them for the
gun we should keep this image better and
they're all so soft and Gaussian
mutations which had different kinds of
medium and we can play and add more
polygons but you can see how the image
ok I'm going to move this out
okay I'm not going to my house well I'll
keep it running and once I switch to
another tab from make it much slower but
luckily i have another tab open with the
same image and I don't think you can
just blow I can go to this year and I
put your father right and it will create
your photo of the next thing and is also
genetic algorithm but now it's a bit
more fun so fresh so those things their
cars each car has different parameters
which are the engineering Academy each
card and different size of the wheel is
different density of wheels if it's
darker is more dense it could slider /
dance give the car shape is blue it
means it's the car which made it which
got the best result during the last try
it and also you can see a shadow or the
previous best car so you can see this
car was modified Elizabeth and became
better
so over time we're going to I can
consider 20 cars here and there is this
chart this church just shows how well
the cars are doing and so far the best
car 105 minutes and you can see on the
small map how's it going and over time
they're going to become really fast
they're going to go really far up with
this emblem and we have some parameters
here there is mutation rate it basically
means how often we want to change the
car because I give the cars away with
the project that want to change much of
it and for this we have second frame the
risk of mutations sighs so for example
this car is doing great and the goddess
random change random chance we've said
all this movie
the shape from the body and this second
for intimidation size says how we can be
paid if it's one hundred percent we can
just be completely random number and we
chew this and funny looking completely
different but the car will keep the same
wheels and the same density and the idea
is to adjust parameters to get the best
results and I actually have a different
time
yeah so this is one of the image and
it's been running for four hours already
and cooking show equivalent what just
happened I've never seen it before yeah
so are you know is what me to try yet
and this is very good so far and
hopefully over time I got on this
website there I see exempt arranged for
seven days with the appellant but I
gunston this is really good yeah let me
share the cars detection more fun
so here you can see how they should
learn how to write
about
and next we'll show you the best one
actually the more time you spend on it
the better i become until someone
there we go this is better than cat
is the course random yeah normally it is
random I use C so like I detect lab 49
here it will generate exactly the same
track and before I actually run this for
several days and they were like flying a
really fast and they went really far and
do more things I'd like to show is but
finding algorithms so ways very
different ways to find out from one
point to another this is something which
is normally used in games but will also
see some real life wait to use it as
well so this one is very simple you can
just build a wall and then you can play
with different parameters and see how
it's going to find a path from window
there are different algorithms which do
this like we can try dykes research
which is actually a graph searching
algorithm and it's not optimized for a
pathfinding and I was for this so just
blindly goes everywhere
and now I'm going to show some real life
use this thing so it's google maps so
can take the same algorithms and we can
see how google maps use it to find the
first one
so let's try extra now
and it shows how important it is to find
the right of it and hear ya so Google
Maps would use the xserve algorithm to
spend like hours trying to view
throughout like manhattan from brooklyn
or something and i believe it's each for
me it's a very short presentation but so
i tweeted the link to our guerrilla
Dacians there is some other cool stuff
like there are robots they're like
people who are learning how to work with
genetic algorithm and I wasn't patient
enough to actually see them working yeah
so take a look I let me put my twitter
handle
Oh
so it's too much
any questions how are you oh then so
Jake Jake algorithm actually show you it
actually used in multiple places mostly
for machine learning but there was
really cute example yeah so NASA
actually used to find the optimal shape
for with some space antenna and this is
what we found and check the emissions
that a person trying to come up with a
formal to find this but basically the
plenty of use cases where it's actually
using real boat
officials comparative generic hour which
from the last
so the question was how genetic
algorithm determines that the result is
better than the previous one so for
example with the cars you can see if it
went further than the previous one it is
doing better with Mona Lisa should just
close it I guess
we just take each pixel and calculate
the difference in color between what we
head there in original and we basically
just to subscribe the hex numbers we add
them up all of them and the smaller this
number the better did this consent and
the shoulder visit your defining a
fitness and this is one thing you have
to have the huge genetic algorithm you
have to understand how to calculate the
fitness
of your guests or less
how do you get the nice guy the question
is how do I guess the next step the next
step is completely random so let's go
think about change about it and there
are things like say to help just like
three polygons maybe not the best
examples and now but let's say we have
like three polygons the background and
then darker polygons for hair and
sunlight for a gun for face that's what
we actually would like to him but
imagine we just have some green praveen
for the guns in that corner to the left
and basically it will match the colors
really well and it will be really hard
for it to actually get to other parts of
the picture because like oh I'm in the
right place and if we would have more
for the gossip would be great but if you
just have three polygons in the corner
they will never be on the whole image
and this is sanic we just go local
maximum or local meaning and this means
that genetic algorithm doesn't always
get you the perfect solution but it just
get there as close as it can be and this
is how you have different ways to relate
things so sometimes it's great to just
adjust things a little bit here and
there and sometimes just want to start
over for some polygons Sanchez then
computed for place
the best
but it's hard to say with this the best
it depends on what you're trying to do
if you were doing some very heavy
regulations and produce something well
level X equal possible but like all the
visualization that it showed you they
were damaged JavaScript
they did